Sabrina Spellman has cast has spooky
spell over Netflix in a dark and twisted
new tale yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's
Jan here and today I'm talking all about
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina what
the season 1 ending really means some
crucial details you might have missed in
the finale and my season 2 theories keep
watching to the end where I'll explain
what we might see feline Salem actually
speak next season spoilers ahead so take
care if you're not all caught up or if
you prefer tap here to watch my spoiler
free review all season Sabrina resists
pledging her allegiance to the Dark Lord
but when Miss Wardwell resurrects the
Greendale 13 who interns summon the red
angel of death Sabrina is pressured into
signing her name in the book of the
Beast doing this moves Sabrina's powers
to a new level allowing her to summon
forth Hell fire which burns the souls of
the reanimated witches now there's an
interesting detail here which you'll
need to look carefully out because the
scenes quite dark but as Sabrina
completes her transformation into a full
witch you can see white streaks taking
over her hair we can appreciate that
more fully in the final shot of the
episode and it's actually a nice nod to
Sabrina's white hair in the comics
Sabrina's definitely embraced her darker
nature strutting along and seemingly
leading the weird sisters now and you
can see Nicolas scratches rather
concerned reaction when he sees this
which is understandable when you
consider the sisters nefarious deeds
this season also revealed in the finale
is why miss Wardwell aka Lilith or madam
Satan works so hard to manipulate
Sabrina into signing her name in the
book of the Beast by securing Sabrina's
allegiance madam Satan believes she'll
soon reign as Queen of Hell as a reward
her familiar stole us however points out
that it seems more likely that Satan's
true plan is to groom Sabrina to sit on
the throne by his side mother ma Satan's
clearly displeased with this idea and
snaps the Crows neck indicating that if
that does happen she'll deal with
Sabrina in a similar fashion if we go
back over the season there's plenty of
clues that suggests the Dark Lord has a
more particular interest in Sabrina than
Lilith might like to think consider how
powerful Sabrina became after signing
her name in the book and when she
summoned Hellfire against the Greendale
13 she became only the
which in history to ever achieve that
there seems to be something about
Sabrina that makes her special interest
to Satan remember that the marriage of
Edward Spellman to the mortal Diana was
approved by a special dispensation with
Satan himself even blessing the Union
but Edward had to offer his child in
exchange
perhaps Satan's interested in her human
half because it could afford him some
additional power or hold over the mortal
world let me know if you've got any
theories
Madame Satan will prove no pushover
though next season as she still got
Brina fooled that Miss Wardwell is just
a regular witch and I think she'll be
able to continue tricking Sabrina into
thinking she's a helpful Ally for some
time however something I noticed in Ward
Wales final scene is that she has the
red angel of death figurine displayed
prominently on her mantelpiece that
seems to be the same figurine that
Ambrose found when he discovered the
Greendale 13 had been resurrected and if
Sabrina or Ambrose notice it next season
they might realize is something up with
miss ward well another twist at the end
of the season was when we discovered
that Zelda has stolen away far the black
woods daughter to raise her together
with Hilda sell delight to Blackwood
about the child because she was actually
the firstborn and therefore his rightful
heir Lady black would have previously
told Zelda that her husband really
wanted a male heir and so Zelda feared
for the baby girl's safety it's quite
possible Blackwood might deliberately
harm the new baby if he knew she was the
firstborn over her younger twin brother
the Church of night is ours boys this is
the Dark Lord's sign his blessing that
we are in the right hail to my firstborn
son hail Judas a quick side note here
notice how horrified Ambrose is at
what's going on in this scene which will
likely put him in conflict next season
with his boyfriend Luke who seems to be
all on board with Blackwood's new
warlock supremacy movement going back to
black woods twin daughter there's
another potential kink in Zelda's plan
to raise a girl who might challenge
black woods attempt to establish an
all-male hierarchy at the Church of
Knight and that is prudence this season
prudence discovered that she's black
woods daughter Bert's because she was
born out of wedlock her claim as his
heir comes
second to Blackwood's children born of
his wife however remember what Sabrina
told Peru if you were father Blackwood's
daughter you could one day lay claim to
the Church of night this school
everything but you'd have to get rid of
his legitimate heirs first so what if
prudence decides to hatch her own plot
to dispatch both of Blackwood's
legitimate children
it really feels that the show is setting
up some serious battles over who runs
the Church of night next season one
mystery set up this season that I'm
hoping we'll get some answers to in
season two is what really happened with
Sabrina's parents zeldron Hilda
repeatedly insists there was no foul
play involved in their death
however the weird sisters dropped a big
hint that that's probably not the case
you don't want what happened to your
mother and father to happen to you where
did you say the accident that took their
life it would be tragic if a similar one
befell you for the Blackwood definitely
had issues with Edward Spellman's ideas
about reforming the Church of night and
we know that madam Satan also resents
Sabrina's parents when the mother of
demons takes over miss Ward wells body
she curses Edward and calls Diana a
mortal sow in the chilling adventures of
Sabrina comics madam Satan and Edward
Spellman were originally lovers until he
betrayed her in favor of Diana and it'll
be interesting to see whether that also
becomes part of madame Satan's backstory
in the TV show like Sabrina anthill 2
discovers a new path for herself by the
end of the season when she strikes up a
relationship with bookstore owner dr.
Cerberus with Hilda's confidence in
herself growing she decides she wants
some more autonomy from her sister and
announces she's moving out of the room
they share together but there's a hint
that things won't play out so smoothly
because as dr. Cerberus walks away from
the Spellman house his eyes flash for a
split second suggesting there's another
side to the book store owner in Greek
mythology Cerberus was a multi-headed
dog who kept watch over the gates to the
underworld and whatever doctor services
true nature is that'll be interesting to
see what party plays next season as for
Sabrina's romantic situation although
she clearly still loves Harvey in the
final scene they share together she
tells him that something dark has
awakened inside her so it's not safe for
her to be around him this is a familiar
trope we've seen
times in film and TV especially for
superheroes for example spider-man
decides it's too dangerous for him to be
with Mary Jane but these things never
really work out and so even if Sabrina
has a fling with Nick her true feelings
will probably remain with Harvey and
this love triangle could be dangerous if
Nick ends up falling for Sabrina Nick
previously said he was jealous of how
mortals love each other and he seems to
hold a special affection for Brina a hot
topic for many fans of the old-school
sabrina sitcom is her cat Salem who in
this new series only spoke out loud
briefly in season one and that was in
his goblin form when he introduced
himself as her familiar however when we
hear madam Satan's crow talking to her
in the finale
I do think the showrunners may be
teasing the possibility of a talking
Salem in season two I don't expect we'll
be getting the kind of sassy and
sarcastic wit that was so iconic and
Sabrina the Teenage Witch but it
probably wouldn't fit the tone of the
new show but I think some more Salem
talking moments would help develop his
character a bit more and give us some
more insight into his personality
there's been a lot of talk about a
Riverdale crossover with Sabrina
and there were lots of references to the
popular CW show in the first season of
chilling adventures plus a surprise
cameo which I talk more about in my
other Sabrina video there's a college
for that here plus a link in the video
description below I suspect that for the
moments in season two any crossover
would be limited to a cameo again
because a full-on crossover might be
tricky to pull off given the differing
aesthetics of the two shows
however Sabrina or Harvey could turn up
briefly in Riverdale to set up a more
substantial crossover in the future and
with Riverdale seeming to go full-on
supernatural in season 3 a cameo like
this could be feasible to pull off let
me know if you've got any thoughts on
how the show should cross over now what
were your favorite moments this season
and do you have any theories or things
you'd like to see next on chilling
adventures for example do you want to
see a talking Salem in season 2 I've
added a poll where you can vote just tap
in the top right of this video and after
you've cast your vote you'll be able to
see the results the winners of my
Halloween merch competition are on the
screen now if that's you then send me an
email with your details so I can send
you the prize tapleft to watch my top 10
differences between the new Sabrina and
her 1990's sitcom
or tap right for another video you're
sure to LIKE and if you enjoyed this I
really appreciate a thumbs up and a
share thanks for watching and see you
next time you be going movie lovers